>>> TONIGHT, THE FBI STEPPING UP
THE INVESTIGATION INTO DEATH
THREATS AGAINST ELECTION WORKERS
IN FULTON COUNTY.
THIS IS ACCORDING TO RICHARD
BARON WHO MET WITH INVESTIGATORS
SEEKING MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
THREATS TO HIM LIKE THIS AND I
WILL WARN YOU THAT WHAT YOU'RE
ABOUT TO HEAR JUST ONE OF MANY
THREATS THAT HE GOT IS
DISTURBING.
>> 234 YEARS AGO THE FOUNDING
CAUCASIAN FATHERS OF AMERICA
GAVE US A SECOND AMENDMENT.
TIME IS RUNNING OUT, RICHARD.
WE'RE COMING AFTER YOU AND EVERY
MOTHER [ BLEEP ]ER THAT STOLE
THIS ELECTION WITH OUR SECOND
AMENDMENT.
YOU WILL BE SERVED LEAD.
>> THAT WAS ONE OF MANY IN THE
FLOOD OF THREATS CAME IN AFTER
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP SINGLED
OUT BARON AT A RALLY IN DECEMBER
AND TRIED TO TIE HIM TO A
DEBUNKED CONSPIRACY THEORY THEY
PULLED OUT SUIT CASES FULL OF
PROBIDEN BALLOTS DURING A WATER
PIPE BREAK IN ATLANTA.
>> IF YOU JUST TAKE THE CRIME OF
WHAT THOSE DEMOCRAT WORKERS WERE
DOING AND BY THE WAY, THERE WAS
NO WATER MAIN BREAK.
>> OKAY.
I WANT TO GO TO RICHARD BARON,
THE ELECTION'S DIRECTOR IN
FULTON COUNTY.
LET ME START WITH THE MEETING
YOU HAD WITH THE FBI AS PART OF
THEIR INVESTIGATION INTO THE
THREATS MADE AGAINST YOU AND
OTHERS IN YOUR OFFICE.
WHAT DO YOU UNDERSTAND ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION AT THIS POINT?
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT THEY ARE
AIMING TO DO IS TO LOOK AT ALL
OF THE THREATS THAT WERE
RECEIVED POST NOVEMBER ALL THE
WAY THROUGH THIS SUMMER.
I KNOW THAT NOT ONLY ME BUT
OTHER PEOPLE ON MY STAFF HAVE
RECEIVED THREATS ALL THE WAY
INTO THE SUMMER AND I KNOW
THAT'S HAPPENED AROUND THE
COUNTRY, AS WELL.
>> SO I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
OBVIOUSLY, YOUR TENURE HAS HAD
CONTROVERSY.
YOU BARELY SURVIVE TO OUST YOU
BY A BIPARTISAN COUNTY BOARD OF
COMMISSIONERS.
NO MATTER WHAT YOU DEAL WITH,
NONE OF IT EXCUSES THE THREATS
YOU RECEIVED LIKE THIS ONE.
>> QUITE OBVIOUS TO ANYBODY WITH
HALF A BRAIN THERE WAS A LOT OF
FRAUD.
I DEMAND SINCE Y'ALL WORK FOR
US, THAT Y'ALL DO SOMETHING AND
IF YOU DON'T, I GUESS WHAT IS IT
TAR-AND FEATHER?
IS IT HANGING FOR TREASON?
OH, BOY, YOU BETTER RUN.
THAT'S ALL I GOT TO SAY.
>> I MEAN, HOW DANGEROUS IS IT
RIGHT NOW FOR YOU TO EVEN DO
YOUR JOB WHEN YOU'RE GETTING
CALLS LIKE THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT YOU HAVE
TO DO IS JUST FOCUS ON GOING TO
WORK EVERY DAY AND DOING WHAT
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO AND TRY TO
IGNORE THE DISTRACTIONS.
I KNOW THAT, YOU KNOW, LISTENING
TO THOSE CALLS NOW IT IS A
LITTLE BIT EASIER TO HEAR THEM
NOW THAN IT WAS IN THE THICK OF
THINGS BETWEEN THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION AND OUR JANUARY SENATE
RUN OFF AND I THINK A LOT OF MY
STAFF THAT'S PREDOMINANTLY BLACK
STAFF AND THEY -- THE "N" WORD
WAS FLYING AROUND WITH IMPUNITY
ON CALLS THEY RECEIVED ALMOST
DAILY FOR A FEW MONTHS.
>> TALK TO ME ABOUT THAT.
YOU SAY YOUR OFFICE IS
PREDOMINANTLY
AMERICANS.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN?
THEY WOULD PICK UP THE PHONE AND
PEOPLE WOULD BE SEEING THESE
HORRIBLE RACIST THINGS AND FROM
MY UNDERSTANDING, TELL ME,
RICHARD, IT WENT FURTHER THAN
THAT.
PEOPLE HAD PEOPLE COMING TO
THEIR HOUSES?
>> YEAH, A LOT OF THE CALLS
DEALT WITH MOTORCYCLE GANGS ON
THEIR WAY TO OUR OFFICES TO
SHOOT US ALL IN OUR OFFICES AND
SEATS.
WE ALSO HAD A COUPLE MEMBERS OF
MY STAFF WERE VISITED AT HOME BY
PEOPLE AT NIGHT AT THEIR
DOORWAY.
ANOTHER LADY HAD HER GRANDMA
VISITED BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT SHE
WAS THERE.
SAID THEY WERE GOING -- THEY
WANTED TO MAKE A CITIZENS ARREST
AND TRIED TO PUSH THEIR WAY INTO
HER GRANDMOTHER'S HOUSE.
>> SO THERE MUST HAVE BEEN TIMES
YOU WERE TRULY SCARED FOR YOUR
LIFE, FOR YOUR FAMILY.
>> WELL, I THINK MOSTLY I WAS
MORE CONCERNED WITH MY STAFF
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, I THINK
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE IN THE
TRENCHES DOING THE WORK WITH
REGARD, IT WAS EASIER FOR ME TO
GET POLICE PROTECTION THAN SOME
OF THE OTHER STAFF BECAUSE THEY
MAY LIVE OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTY
AND THEN IT BECOMES MORE
COMPLICATED TO ARRANGE FOR
POLICE PROTECTION AND I'M -- MY
JOB REQUIRES ME TO LIVE WITHIN
FULTON COUNTY.
>> ALL PRECIATE YOUR TIME, RICH,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> I WANT TO GO TO BEN, A
REPUBLICAN ELECTIONS LAWYER WITH
NEARLY FOUR DECADES OF
EXPERIENCED AND LAUNCHED A
DEFENSE NETWORK FOR OFFICIALS
LIKE RICHARD BARON THAT RECEIVED
THESE THREATS.
SO YOU HEAR RICHARD BARON TALK
ABOUT THE DEATH THREATS HE
RECEIVED AND I PLAYED A COUPLE
OF THEM.
THERE IS COUNTLESS MORE WHERE
THAT CAME FROM.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT MOTORCYCLE
GANGS THREATENING TO SHOOT THEM
IN THEIR SEATS AND SHOWING UP A
AT THEIR HOMES.
HOW DOES HEARING STORIES LIKE
THIS AFFECT YOUR DECISION TO GET
INVOLVED?
>> WELL, VERY MUCH.
I CO-CHAIRED A PRESIDENTIAL
COMMISSION A FEW YEARS AGO WITH
BOB BOWER, WHO IS PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S ATTORNEY.
WE GOT TO KNOW ELECTION
OFFICIALS ON THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL.
THEY DO A TREMENDOUS JOB IN
CALLING BALLS AND STRIKES IN OUR
ELECTIONS.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO CALL
BALLS AND STRIKES.
SO THESE ATTEMPTS TO INTIMIDATE
THOSE ELECTION OFFICIALS
COMBINED WITH THE NATIONWIDE
PUSH THAT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
A HAND FULL OF STATES TO
CRIMINALIZE THE ACTIONS OF
ELECTION OFFICIALS TAKES A HUGE
COST OUT OF THE DEMOCRACY, OUT
OF OUR SYSTEMS OF ELECTIONS,
CREDIBILITY IN ELECTIONS.
>> SO OBVIOUSLY, IT'S NOT JUST
RICHARD BARON AS HE MADE CLEAR
BUT ELECTION OFFICIALS FROM
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY HAVE HAD THE
COURAGE TO SPEAK OUT.
I'VE SPOKEN TO SEVERAL OF THEM,
YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THE THREATS THAT THEY GET,
RIGHT?
THEIR FAMILIES HAVE GOTTEN.
HERE ARE A FEW.
>> WE RECEIVE PHONE CALLS INTO
OUR OFFICES THAT THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, OUR STAFF SAYING
OUR FAMILIES WILL BE
SLAUGHTERED.
>> SEEMED APPARENT THEY WERE
CASING OUR HOUSE TO SEE OUR
SECURITY MEASURES.
>> CALLS TO OUR OFFICES
REMINDING US THAT THIS IS WHAT
THE SECOND AMENDMENT IS FOR.
PEOPLE LIKE US.
>> ALL OF THIS MOTIVATED BY
TRUMP'S BIG LIE ABOUT THE
ELECTION.
NOW, BEN, YOU KNOW, I'VE TALKED
TO YOU THROUGH THIS ENTIRE
ELECTION SITUATION, RIGHT?
OVER THE PAST YEAR.
YOU HAVE WORKED IN ELECTIONS FOR
NEARLY 40 YEARS.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN ANYTHING
>> NO, NEVER LIKE THIS.
NEVER ON SUCH A LARGE SCALE.
NEVER DESIGNED TO REALLY STOP
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS FROM DOING
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO ABOUT THE
CASTING AND COUNTING OF BALLOTS.
AND THAT GOES TO THE PEACEFUL
TRANSFER OF POWER.
SO THESE ATTACKS ON ELECTION
OFFICIALS PLUS THE LAWS BEING
PASSED IN THE STATES PLUS WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th MEANS
THAT IT REALLY IS TIME TO TELL
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS THAT THEY DO
HAVE ALLIES, THAT PEOPLE DO HAVE
THEIR BACKS.
>> SO OBVIOUSLY GOVERNOR ABBOTT
ASSIGNED THE VOTING LAW IN
TEXAS.
YOU WRITE IN AN OP ED THAT IN
JUST THE PAST THREE MONTHS
SEVERAL STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, I'M QUOTING YOU, PASSED
LAWS AND IMPOSED CRIMINAL
PENALTIES FOR, AS YOU SAY,
SIMPLY DOING THEIR JOBS.
THREE OF THESE STATES, TEXAS,
GEORGIA, FLORIDA, TEXAS
YESTERDAY HAVE EMPOWERED
PARTISAN POLL WATCHERS.
THAT'S AN EXPLICIT PART OF THE
LEGISLATION.
WHAT EFFECT IS THAT GOING TO
HAVE?
>> IN THE POLLING PLACE, WHICH
IS DESIGNED TO LET PEOPLE CAST
THEIR BALLOTS PEACEFULLY,
WEAPONIZED POLL WATCHERS CAN
CAUSE, NUMBER ONE, DISRUPTION
AND INTIMIDATORS TO VOTERS AND
NUMBER TWO DISTRACT ELECTION
OFFICIALS FROM DOING THEIR JOB.
THE REALLY SURPRISING THING TO
ME IN ALL OF THIS IS THE
REPUBLICANS THAT WERE PASSING
THESE LAWS SEEM TO HAVE NO
RECOGNITION THAT THIS CAN BE
USED AGAINST